hey it's been a while it's been a while
since i've done a walking dead video
haven't it couple years
few years but the walking dead season 10
is getting six more episodes starting
this sunday an extended season i'm
excited for it i want to talk about it
full transparency amc was like
are you interested in doing a video on
the walking dead because you know
promotions and whatnot they're amping it
up to which i had some thoughts uh one
it has to be in my own words and it has
to be honest integrity's important here
so there's that
two um i like the walking dead so that
works out and
three i was gonna do this video anyway
i mean i didn't tell them that i guess
now they know don't hate the player hate
the game that is to say this video is
sponsored by amc but my thoughts on this
video are my own
that's important you know the reason i'm
looking forward to more episodes of
season 10
is because i've seen seasons nine and
ten like i hadn't
i hadn't watched seasons nine and ten i
get the feeling there are a lot of
people out there in that same boat and
last year sometime i was like i'm gonna
binge walking dead seasons nine and ten
and i did and it was really good like
the walking dead at the top of their
game
kind of good it was a really good binge
you know the kind of binge that you
think about you're like oh good memories
that binge yes
the most exciting things that happened
in my life are binging shows but they
made some bold moves like andrew lincoln
left the show not that i didn't like him
as rick grimes i don't know the reasons
he actually left the show
but rick was gone which allowed some
characters that i felt were kind of in
rick's shadow to come to the forefront
they also did like a six-year time jump
so people are in a different place now
also great antagonist with alpha the all
the skin walkers they were
it was a really fascinating look at a
group of people who learned to navigate
this super death walker apocalypse and
last but not least arguably most
importantly
it felt like horror again there were
moments in seasons 9 and 10
that felt like horror it's called the
walking dead
it should so it injected an energy into
the walking dead it revitalized it in a
way i
really dug so although the story of
alpha is now wrapped
i can't help but look forward to six
extra episodes of the walking dead
season 10 as long as i can keep that
creativity momentum going which if you
see the trailer it looks like it deals
with that organization i believe it's
the same organization that got
rick right so that's where rick is and i
wonder how that's gonna work out because
at this point i mean it's not like rick
was like hey i'm gonna enlist
but if you look at it if he is with
these people
he's been with wherever he is longer
than he was with
the the crew of the walking dead so i
wonder where his loyalties lie
i'm not counting on rick coming back i'm
not saying hey andrew lincoln's
definitely going to be in it i'd like to
see him but if i don't still
i'm fascinated at this organization that
definitely looks like they have
funding like everyone else has been
scraping for berries and scraps and you
know they got the windmills and
we just kind of have to rebuild
civilization and these other folks are
like it's fine we have tech we're going
to steamroll everybody it's
just that's how and maggie's now come
back like maggie was gone
for seasons nine and ten i didn't really
know where she was
and now she's come back i'm not gonna
lie to you i'm not as interested as to
where she was as i
am i just want her and negan to get into
a room together it's as simple as that
the simple men have simple wants
that's a want because they use negan
differently in seasons nine and ten too
because you know negan
he has done some stuff we've seen it we
remember
and there's an old phrase that comes
from the land of nosgoth and that is
time
fades even legend until twitter digs it
back up
but time fades even legend which worked
for the walking dead and them going
look we like jeffrey dean morgan we love
negan and you know i love him
i think he's a great charismatic actor
and i think negan
is a charismatic character i wanted to
see more of him
but yeah we had to move on to other
villains it was time but still let's use
negan so they kind of turned him into
this anti-hero
he's almost like this really hardcore
yet kind of cool
uncle to judith grimes you can tell he's
trying to be better but he was used so
well
in that anti-hero capacity in seasons 9
and 10
that i'm really interested in maggie
coming back because i'm sure she doesn't
care
she doesn't care that he's some
anti-hero now no she remembers
time fades even legends fades slower for
maggie but maggie
has her kid that she had with glenn so
is she gonna go on full revenge spree i
don't know i mean when you have a kid
your priorities
change you know you gotta think like oh
can i do this thing and
will that put the kid in danger will i
put my son in danger or daughter or
whoever but in her case son
or maybe i'm seeing it wrong maybe i'm
seeing that through the lens of our
society
less than civil but still not the lens
of super death walker apocalypse so i
don't know we see the backstory of negan
and his wife lucille who is the namesake
of negan's bat lucille
usually i like villain backstories to be
a little ambiguous to where you can kind
of it's implied or you piece it together
however this does afford a great
opportunity
because you know that story is going to
be sad and that can really melt some
internet minds you can really make
people feel conflicted if you can show a
heartbreaking backstory to someone who
was like the
king villain of a show like negan was in
the walking dead and you can make people
feel bad for him
i'm just totally down for audiences
feeling conflicted like that and dig it
never waste an opportunity
that's a good one and also by
implication yeah we get the backstory of
lucille the bat and yes not
since the jose canseco bat that casey
jones tried to use on rafael in central
park have
been so interested in the backstory of a
bat so the walking dead season 10
being extended by six episodes i'm
digging that and i'll be there watching
it if you're feeling it i'll
bring you videos on those episodes
because tv's kind of where my views are
right now i make no promises but i'll
see where it goes
and the episodes actually premiere on
amc plus earlier in the week the first
episode's already out so you got to jump
on that but i won't lie
all of this interesting excitement comes
because i binge seasons nine and ten
like if you haven't seen it yet
give it a shot you might be surprised
all right so the walking dead
seasons nine and ten as they stand right
now and six new episodes of season 10
coming at you what do you think of all
that whatever you think comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
you